was it an intentional thing not to put
out any videos for MTV because one of
the things I dug about the band in the
early days was it was mysterious well
for me I remember we wanted to have a
video on there they would they wouldn't
touch us for sure we were not Asia or
whatever all the other you know videos
that were up there we weren't that they
were kind of the enemy you know and
basically what I remember of it is there
was so much talk about Metallica why
don't you have a video for Metallica so
it's like the fans and the people around
us was requesting something so it kind
of put it in their minds like hey we
need to pay attention to this band so it
was almost like now they're asking us to
do a video and we get to do what we
would like to do not we have to fit
their mold did you guys make videos
before that and submit them to MTV and
they'd say [__] you we're not putting no
no wow no I mean there was definitely
there was definitely an element at that
time of we don't belong and we don't fit
in and we're not part of of that cool
club and so we've played both sides of
that which is we're not cool enough to
be on MTV and that can really quickly
when you douse a little bit of cynicism
on top of that then it's like well [__]
you we don't want to be on MTV you know
what I mean that's a real fine line yeah
and so up through those years
it was like well we don't want to play
the game we don't want to bow to the man
to the to the record business to all
that type of stuff there was definitely
a lot of pride in the fact that we were
hovering on the outer fringes and that
we weren't part of the mainstream but
were people telling you like man you
guys got to get with it your careers
aren't going to last I mean there must
have been a tremendous amount of
pressure to put some spandex on and get
on MTV so we didn't feel too much
pressure but
it it as the records kept coming out and
there was no video it almost became a
thing you know Metallica is the one band
that's not releasing a video and then
finally on the Injustice for all album
we had the song one and somebody had the
idea that this was a song that could
really be visualized in a way that would
fall outside of that
kind of hair and Spandex and and that
formula that 95 of the videos were at
that time there was something dark about
that song and there was something
obviously Sinister and really unique
about it and there was the material from
the Johnny goddess Gun movie and then I
think it was cliff and a few other
people kind of came up with this idea
about doing a video in the spirit of the
Johnny got his gun movie and actually
intercutting it with that footage and
then off we went on our first video
adventure and
it it felt like it was just the right
time you know it was uh after uh holding
back for so long it was like here we go
and um when that when that video came
out in February of 89 remember dial MTV
uh it was all about dial MTV every
afternoon on that Monday it premiered it
premiered straight at number one and it
literally changed it was it was one of
those monumental
days where it was just like holy [__]
this is real there are
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people out there that want something
different than the formulaic stuff
they're being fed and so that was a
really big day when when one went
straight in at number one that first day
and stayed there for like the next eight
years what a victory